I get nervous sometimes I you ever
thought about it oh yeah I've thought
about it yeah when I was like you know
from age you know 12 to 16 every white
kid does you know so then I definitely
did but now I think I would want to be
Mexican next I think for me black still
seemed a little too risky I would wait
one more another year before you double
another cycle like another life cycle
all right
like reincarnated one time be Latino and
there was risky now just getting black
or risky do black like in the chorus
it's still too risky for me I get
nervous a lot I know I have fear and
anxiety yeah yeah yeah if you get
nervous now you wouldn't be good yeah
not definite you couldn't have no
traffic stop zero do black people get
nervous cuz it always seemed like to me
when I was growing up I honestly don't
know that black people never got I was
like [ __ ] black people do not get nerve
now we do procedure we use different
language like you call it nervous and
then black might call it shook right you
don't say like he wasn't nervous now I
was it's the same definition where were
you nervous now I was just a little
shook yeah I mean we just don't identify
with certain things like when it comes
to uh like depression yeah white people
can identify with depression anxiety
posts whatever pros yeah that stress
they could deal with that you know
saying but you as a white person are you
stressed yeah I'm really stressed you
stress black prayers like nine stress
I'm just a little [ __ ] up his the
words you use you know I've said and I
know like like Charlemagne the guy has
his book cause shook one and he was
talking about disfigure more black
people dealt with mental issues and he's
as a person he said from presidents pan
a therapist $100 hour to talk to him
about problems yeah I was black person
from the hood
can't afford a therapist right good for
is a bag of weed yeah a bottle of
Hennessy and that's what we looked
through that's how we get get we deal
with mental issues it's not the way it
should be but we don't use the same
words because you get different drugs
you don't say when you say well you say
I'm a little stressed out anxiety you
get prozac xanax and all that type [ __ ]
if you say that to a blood president you
get weed yeah
I try to give you a loan and blow you're
saying is that it's not the right thing
to do but it's just different
definitions I say you know all right and
all of us below [ __ ] them right now but
the whole thing about being a little
[ __ ] right now is how you cope with
think coping is is none what they have
to deal with with any mental issues can
you cope with it yeah do they have like
unique mental issues that you think
black guys get that white guys don't get
I don't know if this is a mental issue
but a lot of black guys give a white
guys can't well they can but like jungle
fever yeah you know I'm saying I don't
think that that's a mental disorder but
it's something it's something that's a
little taboo in a black community
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this because this is alarming